Gavin Newsom lizard person Gavin Newsom
out of California he is very upset that
Ron DeSantis sent 36 illegal immigrants
not migrants or any other software
illegal immigrants who broke the law by
coming here in the first place uh Rhonda
Santa sent him on a plane to California
and Gavin Newsom despite the fact that
he's got a sanctuary State and his
Sanctuary cities and nobody's illegal
and we love diversity and it's our
strength he's not happy about it I'm
very confused
these flights of Asylum Seekers that are
being brought to Sacramento there have
been two of them now they've been
described as state-sanctioned kidnapping
by the Attorney General of of this state
of California you tweeted directly at
the governor of Florida Ron DeSantis I
want to get this right you called him a
small pathetic man and asked quote
kidnapping charges is that is that what
you believe happened governor who's on
the Florida kidnapped migrants and
brought them to California I think I've
been generous small and pathetic
uh very generous he's just weakness
masquerading his strength
yeah he's flailing
desperate for attention let's just level
sit here let's level set here's a
governor from the state of Florida
that is using taxpayer money and he had
to go to another state
to find people under false pretense I
don't think this I know this I talked to
the migrants lied to them took them into
another state by bus and then took them
on a chartered flight to Sacramento
lying to them that they had help on the
other side knocked on the door and they
left these migrants right there on the
steps what kind of human being does that
guys let's level set right here I I
really think Gavin Newsom is the devil
like if the devil exists in in human
form his disconnects from the truth
actually makes him devil-like uh before
I let you guys try man I thought I've
had a particularly good tweet on this if
I dare quote myself on my own show let's
put this up uh lizard person Gavin
Newsom is very upset that Ron DeSantis
sent 36 illegal immigrants to California
why doesn't he just uh house them on his
Vineyard maybe he could even find work
for them I'm sure they'd enjoy a nice
glass of Pinot Noir after their long
Voyage here's a link for the other
illegals who want to swing by looks
pretty swag so that's his Winery plump
Jack Winery and looks like he's got
plenty of room there and he said he's a
sanctuary state in a sanctuary City so I
don't know what he's so upset by also I
haven't heard one single person in
Florida complaining that any dollars
were used to get illegals out of here we
are a law an order state uh Ashley I
don't like Gavin Newsom take it from
there
um yeah I don't like it much either and
he he was married when I lived in San
Francisco and you just got a kind of a
greasy feel off of him and absolutely
you know you you would think that if he
were really behind his message about
being a sanctuary State and believing in
that in principle he would spend the
time on air welcoming those people to
his State and uh accepting all the
benefit that they bring but you know I
think there's there's also the this
other case of you know what's going on
in California and I think this is kind
of a great way to distract from that
where we have
tens of thousands if not many more
people dying of Fentanyl and
homelessness and related
um diseases and Addictions on the
streets of California on the Streets of
San Francisco and Los Angeles and that
is a crisis I mean 36 people you know
maybe it's unseemly to fly them across
country or whatever I don't know and I
don't really care but I do think when
you've got tens of thousands of young
people and and people of All Sorts dying
on the streets of the wealthiest state
in the nation and and you know by the
sixth largest economy in the world as as
it's usually uh portrayed I think you've
got a real big question as to why he's
not talking about that issue